(upbeat pop music)
(audience applauds)
♪ Been around the world and I, I, I ♪
♪ I can't find my baby ♪
♪ I don't know when, I don't know why ♪
♪ Why he's gone away ♪
♪ And I don't know where he can be ♪
♪ My baby ♪
♪ But I'm gonna find him ♪
♪ Mm, we had a quarrel
and I let myself go ♪
♪ I said so many things,
things he didn't know ♪
♪ I was, oh, oh, so bad ♪
♪ I don't think he's coming back, mm ♪
♪ He gave the reasons,
the reasons he should go ♪
♪ And he said some things
he never said before ♪
♪ He was, oh, so mad ♪
♪ And I don't think he's
coming back, coming back, no ♪
♪ I did too much lying ♪
♪ Wasted too much time ♪
♪ Now I'm here and crying, I, I, I ♪
♪ Been around the world and I, I, I ♪
♪ I can't find my baby ♪
♪ I don't know when, I don't know why ♪
♪ Why he's gone away ♪
♪ And I don't know where he can be ♪
♪ My baby ♪
♪ But I'm gonna find him ♪
♪ Been around the world ♪
♪ Looking for my baby ♪
♪ And I'm gonna find him ♪
(audience cheering)